as we count down the days to this year's
next 2023 I'll be sharing some first
looks at duet Ai and Google cloud in
case you missed it earlier this year at
Google I O we announced duet AI an
entire system of tools to help
developers build applications in the
cloud so let's take a look at some sneak
peeks of these new features that we'll
be talking more about at next today
let's take a look at IDE based code
assistance this can be used on a local
IDE such as vs code IntelliJ or within
Google Cloud workstations duet AI will
give you the ability to generate entire
Java classes or Google Cloud friendly
code but you'll have to tune into next
to learn more in the meantime check out
the links in our description to register
or to sign up to be part of Google
Cloud's AI trusted tester program